good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight mid fall elections are coming up
and a lot is at stake and not just some
of the policy questions if democrats win
and at this point that could definitely
happen maybe it's even likely to happen
they will immediately try to impeach the
president now they claim they're not
planning to do that but that's untrue
they've wanted to impeach Trump since
the day he took office the first crime
they alleged you'll remember was
collusion with Russia then they claimed
obstruction of justice for firing Jim
Comey because firing people the federal
government is by definition obstruction
after that they fantasized about
appeasing the president for the supposed
crime of pulling out of the Paris
climate of course then it was the
immigrant family separation and then it
was the Helsinki press conference with
Vladimir Putin which they told us was
treason
now there's the news this week that
Trump paid off an ex-girlfriend in an
extortion scheme they're claiming that's
impeachable to no doubt there will be
other high crimes they tell us about in
the near future
the pretext doesn't really matter
actually Democrats want to remove Trump
from office because they hate him that's
the reason if they get their
congressional majority back they will
start that process on day one they will
have to do that because their base
demands that they do that look at the
polls that tells you the whole story
Republicans of course are horrified by
all of this but they shouldn't be
horrified by it unlike a special counsel
investigation or sabotage by career
federal bureaucrats impeachment is
legitimate it is a constitutional
process if you think a president has
committed high crimes you impeach him
that's what the document tells us to do
you put him on trial in Congress you
present your evidence you let the Senate
decide guilt or innocence
there's nothing secretive about it or
stealthy it all takes place in public it
is a totally transparent process voters
get to decide what they think and then
they render their judgment at the ballot
box last time Congress impeach the
president voters did not like it at all
they punished the party that did it the
Republicans in the midterm elections of
1998 that was 20 years ago but Democrats
who have a long memory remember it well
and that's why they're lying about their
intent to impeach Trump right now
Democratic lawmakers act like the
thought of impeachment has barely
crossed their minds if peach but really
what it's the same tactic they use with
immigration and so many other issues
hide their real goals
and hope the country doesn't notice well
we have noticed so let's have an honest
debate about it joining us now is
Christie Setzer she's president of new
heights communications Christie thanks
for coming on glad to be here so you
will concede I hope that there's really
no and by the way this is not an attack
as I just noted million observation
there's really no question that
Democrats will have to initiate
impeachment proceedings against Trump if
they retake the house I'm not sure about
that what I do think is that Democrats
want some measure of accountability I
think that we've been extremely
frustrated to not to put too fine a
point on it by the last 20 months in
which no matter what Trump has done
whether it has been a series of things
that most Americans find immoral or an
American or even at this point actively
criminal behavior Republicans have sat
on their hands and done nothing about it
we've seen hearing after hearing on
Hillary's emails but none on let's say
to get to the bottom of the Trump Tower
meeting well there has been quite a I
think I mean I think we've covered it
maybe every night for the last year and
a half this Russia investigation two of
them actually one initiated by Congress
the other by the Special Counsel but I
just don't understand why everyone's so
embarrassed of impeachment that is the
constitutional remedy it's a political
process it's designed to be a political
process the rest of us can participate
in it by voting why are we lying why are
Democrats lying about impeachment oh
well we're not really sure of course
you're gonna impeach and you should
impeach him if you think he committed
crimes impeach him why is that a scary
thing to say because it's one of many
options right right now we're looking at
several different ways I believe that
the president could be held accountable
the biggest one and the most salient one
I think for most Democrats are the
November elections in which yes there
will be measures to hold the president
accountable if Democrats take back the
house and help maybe even maybe even the
Senate but the other way is judicial
accountability we are now talking about
a president who has potentially
committed crimes he was the unindicted
co-conspirator in Michael Kelley but
before I ask you about that crime yeah
let me just a gas for the third time
this question why not just say the most
accountable form yeah of accountability
is impeachment because it's transparent
unlike the the legal proceedings for
watching certainly unlike the creepy
Special Counsel investigation
there's something hidden about
impeachment you present your evidence in
public in an open court why are
Democratic leaders lying about that well
we're not really sure if you think he
committed crunch why wouldn't you
impeach him what is the answer honestly
I think the answer honestly is that some
people have called for that but the
political reality is that you take 67
votes in the Senate oh the public
doesn't like it oh I get it because if
there was public there was broad public
support for it then you would do it but
if he's such an obvious criminal why
isn't there public support for it well
the real question is why isn't the
Republican support for it right that is
the political reality orders don't want
it that's why yeah it's pretty simple
it's given that again the president
because they've committed a crime
disagree more than one federal crime
because they disagree with you and
disagree me I still allowed
despite the left's attempts to
criminalize it we're allowed to disagree
still for this brief moment so again my
question is if it's so obvious the
president has committed all these crimes
what isn't the majority of America want
him impeached I'm confused
I'm not sure that they don't to be
honest but again I think it'll more
again the more immediate goal for for
Democrats should be political
accountability and judicial you have
political accountability is called
impeachment but you don't want to do it
because despite all the carping about
how he's a criminal
you still haven't convinced the public
of that and I wonder if that gives you
pause you spend two years telling
everyone that he's a racist and a felon
but they still don't believe it maybe
they don't believe you
I think the views on actually are
changing if you look at okay the
Democratic base for example they
actually do want that and I know already
and the majority of independents do as
well but at the same time again I don't
think that that should be the only odd
but it's the legitimate one it's rather
than use entrench career federal
bureaucrats to undermine the president
in really the least legitimate possible
way why not just man up and do it in an
honorable Constitution that's my plea to
you please do it let's get to the crime
so you will concede that he was extorted
by stormy Daniels he paid her over a
hundred grand because he didn't want her
to talk that's extortion I think we all
know that is the hanging off a pornstar
to keep silent about something that why
is that not extortion if I say I'm gonna
tell the public about something bad you
did
unless you pay me money that's called
extortion this is actually a pattern of
behavior that Donald Trump has not just
with stormy Daniels but with other women
he's I'm not no I'm just I don't think
he should have paid them and I think
it's immoral that's my view yeah but
paying someone to keep quiet if I demand
that you give me money in order to be
quiet I'm extorting them blackmailing
you which is itself a crime why would
you support that um I would I don't
support is the fact that in Donald
Trump's white house and I believe this
is unprecedented he is asked for not
just NDA it's from everybody who works
there or was on the campaign but also
non-disparagement agreements which means
that nobody who but hold on you're not
answering my question he operates but he
paid her or else she was going to
besmirch his reputation that's extortion
okay but where's the crime I'm totally
missing that I mean I think you could
argue it's immoral to cheat on your wife
you guys don't believe in marriage so
you're not gonna argue that but instead
your arguments if I sit here as a
married woman but yeah obviously that's
the real argument but in sets a campaign
finance violation
it's not it is a campaign finance
violation if you are using money from
the campaign to pay off this woman yes
that's a crime right there but that's
not what he's accused of doing he's not
accused of using campaign donations to
pay her off is he because that would be
a crime I believe he is and that's why
he said no no I use I mean if I'm wrong
I will definitely stand corrected yeah
and I will not defend that by the way
because that would be a flat-out crime
and people go to jail for that
my impression is it's his money that's
nothing to do with the campaign I think
that is what he said although the story
as you know has changed quite a bit from
I didn't know anything about it to me or
my producers who were on this so yeah no
evidence that he used campaign funds
again that would be a crime and I would
be the first to say he should be
prosecuted for that okay but no one's
listed so why is it a crime to accede to
an extortion demand I'm totally honestly
confused the reason why we have been
that people have been very exercised
about this is because this happened at a
really suspicious time right it happened
October before the election so a couple
weeks let's say right after the Access
Hollywood Head tape had come out and it
truly truly damaged his candidacy to the
point of people wondering if he was
actually gonna have to drop
or something heywhy anyway right so it
was going to be coming out potentially
at the same time he wanted to make sure
it didn't okay so okay so you're saying
that people have found out that Donald
Trump might have committed adultery
something he bragged about on Howard
Stern multiple times that they wouldn't
have voted for me even after they saw
the exes Hollywood tape where he bragged
about his low sexual standards so like
actually what you're saying doesn't make
any sense of oh that's actually the case
though is that his ratings his approval
ratings dropped significantly his
polling drops the show only happens
during the 1996 campaign Monica Lewinsky
with a job when she sent her over to
Bill Richardson for job paid her off for
her silence
that wasn't a campaign finance violation
but this president paying off his
girlfriend yes open was extensively
investigated oh no no he definitely was
he's definitely a peach he shouldn't
have been I agree
but he wasn't charge of the campaign
finance violations why is that III think
that they're apples and oranges I'm
calling apples on that Christy I hope
you impeach them so we can just have an
honest conversation about it Thank You
Tucker thank you